pour notre dernière journée avec toute
l'équipe on est parti dans le désert à
tozeur et dès notre arrivée à l'aéroport
il y avait un petit souci puisque
benjamin castaldi s'est fait piéger par
la douane regardez bien là on retrouve
le benjamin castaldi de tf1 qu à
regarder
le reconnaître mon genre
[Musique]
vous avez une jument trait sur juste
contrôle de routine que ce soient les
bienvenus
et parce que vous avez un passeport
armand est ainsi bouclée
si vous faites quoi dans la vie
monseigneur animateurs ont fait
ressurgir et non je connais pas ce à
quoi enflammer
est ce que vous avez acheté six enfants
sont français vous avez une facture pas
la façon à ce que je vais trouver s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
je vais appeler vous reconnaitre
kral de coaching
[Musique]
je dois me montrer respectent pas les
protos en avant la baisse surprise de
taille
hachey chauffer je vais passer mon
expertise jeu
ok est vraiment là quoi vous allez voir
maman ça oui je sais je joue et je vous
laisse couler sa maman non ici c'était
pas falloir débattre sur neuf mois mais
c'est monsieur attendait messieurs
allez dernièrement une héronnière je
recherche un monsieur
ces deux procédures mais non
si nous voulons voir comprenez vous
pouvez pas entrer en tunisie avec en
gérant de façon non non non monsieur
vous s'il vous plaît assez vous lancer
j'ai beau père et moi n'importe quoi
rêver pourquoi messieurs énigmes en
amont très symbolique services quelle
heure ils m'attendent
elle va passer sa machine et pourtant on
va lui servir
c'est bon de voir ses parts à monza
je m'allonge sur trois trous je ne veux
pas c'est donc c'est pas voter pas
membre
alors si vous trouvez que je passais
demandez pas comment vous pouvez quitter
plus globale s'est par avance benoît
kate honda lock out mais c'est pas mal
quand il a voulu me faire arrêter comme
ça on va voir si moi aussi qu'avec moi
c'est l'adn
maintenant le foyer qui vous voulez
le kit répand sur votre montre final
entre 6 et celui l'expérience y est vous
avez la fin aux heurts ils disent qu'ils
m'ont piqué la montre donc c'est
forcément d'une revenus attendus vont et
la facture à je sais pas si tu étais pas
mais pas de parrain de cette façon nos
cieux et les matins on n'a rien péter
messieurs s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît vous permet de présenter d'ici à
l'heure avec deux présents publié
d'ailleurs avec sir le président
tunisien est ma je m'en fous moi je sais
je suis en train de faire mon travail
kouakou la salle assez de nourriture
ok rappelé le président appelait ce que
tu veux ok ça c'est votre montre ça je
ne suis pas content c'est pas mon boulot
ça ou non de ce qu'il doit
[Musique]
c'est pas bien qu'elles tombent les
vampires maintenant j'ai terminé mois au
sol et samedi derniers jours les nazis
non non non non non non en temps vous
êtes policier assermenté monsieur
monsieur monsieur je suis monsieur
monsieur monsieur hockey votre chapeau
et si thomas jacquot votre chapeau et
qui viennent pour votre chapeau c'est
quoi le chèche se dire ok et si votre
net aussi ok mon t-shirt de votre petite
soeur jamais la bible et jamais m votre
t-shirt amène la vie votre t-shirt loose
est temps qu j'avais watchers vous ai
parlé
j'attends ben je l'aidais les coquettes
vous accusez dix ans à venir est il
malgré maintenant prison ok je suis en
prison
allez
[Applaudissements]
tu vas se met à aimer le coût par tonne
un jour je te piège ray et j'ai un peu
l'habitude je vois les caméras toujours
et l'âge au début je les cherche des
caméras je n'ai pas vu donc je me suis
dit [ __ ] ça trop ils vont vraiment
piqué ma montre ça me plaisait pas trop
compliquer ma mon engagement c'est un
grand grand moment et bravo comédien
[Applaudissements]